Okay.
What if we lost all our
coral reefs overnight?
Ocean diving would become less impressive,
that's for sure.
But what about the marine
ecosystems they sustained?
How many sea animals
would face extinction?
Could the corals rebuild
themselves from scratch?
How would this massive die off
affect humanity? This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
all the coral reefs disappeared.
Corals are not rocks.
They're huge colonies of a
distant relative of the jellyfish,
coral polyps and like all living things,
they die.
The warmer oceans get,
the faster coral reefs die out.
It only takes a water temperature spike
of one degree above average to upset
corals and make them turn white.
This process is called bleaching.
It makes corals more vulnerable to hot
temperatures and causes their death.
If the water doesn't cool down,
climate change has already killed half
of the great barrier reefs coral in just
the last two years.
It's only a matter of time until the
last coral vanishes from the oceans.
But what if an abrupt heat
wave destroyed all the reefs?
Overnight coral reefs take up just
1% of the world's marine environment.
So no big deal, right, wrong.
Just that 1% is enough to
sustain a quarter of all
marine animals in the ocean.
2 million species live in on
and around the reefs for them.
Corals have been providing food
and shelter for 50 million years.
The day the reefs disappeared, marine
biodiversity would suffer huge losses.
The ocean bottom would be taken
over in my forest of seaweed.
Maybe it's time to give jellyfish soup a
try since there would be plenty of them
in the ocean, but for many unique
species of fish in the ocean,
corals are their only safe habitat.
A lot of them would be lost for good.
Same goes for sea turtles. Since coral are
filter feeders, they cleaned the water.
Remaining species,
including dolphins would be left
to survive in very murky waters.
They might soon disappear as well
since when the corals disappear,
there would be very little fish for
them to feed on. But what about us?
What humans on land be effected too?
Absolutely. Since reefs support fish,
they also support the fisheries feeding
and giving jobs to 500 million people in
tropical countries like Indonesia,
Malaysia. And the Philippines. Of course,
the local tourism industries you've crash.
No one wants to dive into a forest
of seaweed with no quarrels.
Less coastal countries would lose
$375 billion of annual income.
Coastlines would no longer be protected
from flooding and extreme storms.
Oral provides a natural break water and
a buffer against erosion. Without it,
water would push local
residents out of their homes.
As the ocean spread out,
the residents of these densely populated
islands would have nowhere to go.
The countries might vanish from
the planet together with the reefs.
Without seafood,
there would be increased pressure on
farms to make up for the shortfall in
protein.
This might turn into a global food crisis.
It's hard to predict what else.
The disruption to the food chain and
biodiversity of the oceans would lead to.
Sure enough,
it wouldn't be pretty.
The truth is this hypothetical
scenario is getting very real.
The corals of the Great Barrier Reef are
bleaching quickly and are unlikely to
recover. Can Humans help
their survival? Well,
we aren't able to regrow 500 year
old corals and just 15 years,
but we can at least try to pollute
our air and is less that way.
The coral reefs might be around to give
enjoyment life to future generations of
fish and humans.
The next time you're looking
for a place to go on vacation,
think about the impact you're making and
try to support local communities that
protect the oceans and
ecosystems they depend on.
And if you go diving or snorkeling,
don't stand on the corals.
Always marvel at their incredible
beauty from a distance.